football legend diego maradona widely
considered one of the greatest players
of all time
has died at the age of 60. his attorney
announced he suffered a heart attack
maradona was the captain of the
argentina national team
that defeated germany in the world cup
final in 1986.
he also racked up numerous other titles
and awards
in a career that spanned five decades as
player
and coach he had been in poor health in
recent years
and earlier this month he underwent
surgery for blood clot
in his brain
i want to take you straight now to
buenos aires argentina to sports
journalist sergio rosenthal who joins us
on the phone right now
very very sad news what more can you
tell us
really that it's very very sad
for all country but
not only for argentina country for all
worldwide
people that love soccer today is a
special day that we will remember
for a long time i you know that
argentina people
you know argentina people love
soccer how we live here
in in south america in argentina and
brazil in both countries
we you know we take this soccer
this is very very very special point
for our life let's say
in this kind of words sergio as we're
talking to you about this sad news we're
showing live pictures
from right outside diego maradona's
villa a
vehicle that looks like a forensic
vehicle
just moved in it seems
maradona's health deteriorated in recent
months but he has struggled
with health issues for many years now
as you know i will i will be
very very clear i don't know if my
english is so good
and you can understand but
all of us that knows
diego armando maradona as a player
also he knows very well diego maradona
when
he finished his career and
i need really more than 24 hours to
explain
this this life of this guy
that they die because vigo maradona
is something that it would be become a
legend you know
and of course if i tell you that
and it's not time to compare anything
without
with with another players because also
you in germany
you have a lot of big big players
that i can tell you the bower miller
romani
clothes lot of materials oliver
it's it's something that today for us
for the football
that people that love footballs uh
we are very it is a very very sad day
sergio i can i can hear and i can almost
feel the emotion
in your voice how are people reacting
where you are
it doesn't matter the team that you
are because you know that here there are
two teams boca juniors and river play
that are the most important teams
in the world as you know last year
i don't know why because really i don't
know why for the moment
uh we played the the
the american champion league you know
the in
in spain is something that for the
moment i i will never understand that
but
it doesn't matter uh regarding the
question that you asked me
is that it doesn't matter the team that
you are
the people in argentina all the 45
million people that lives here
are very very sad believe me sports
journalist sergio
rosenthaler reporting from buenos aires
argentina thank you so much for joining
us
and i want to go now
to talk about the larger than life
mythical figure
that was diego maradona with dw's tom
gone who's here with me we could hear
there the
the raw emotion this man meant so much
for an entire
nation so talked about us about the
illustrious career that
was diego maradona yeah well maradona of
course um
a sublime talent and a player who won
trophies in many different countries
um in europe here of course notably in
italy
where he led napoli to their first ever
italian championship in 1987
and their second a few years later in
1990
before that of course a world cup winner
with argentina in 1986
at a tournament where maradona produced
feats of footballing magic that probably
are familiar to every football fan
around the world
whether they were not born yet like
myself or whether they saw them
happening live
in front of them i think everybody can
conjure the images of um
maradona dribbling past about six or
seven players on the england team in the
quarter final on that day
and slotting it past the keeper you know
there are very many players in football
who have achieved and who will achieve
probably more than diego maradona in
terms of trophies in the game
um but they will never be remembered in
the same way
because it's the singular talent of
diego maradona that really makes him a
figure
you know the the figure of such devotion
um for people in argentina of course in
naples
um and in very many other places around
the world an extraordinary footballer
for all the reasons and more
who was also tormented and struggled
were personal demons
yes of course it was during diego
maradona's years playing for napoli um
in italy where he developed a taste for
alcohol and for uh drug abuse which were
to
dog his playing career um ended up
getting him banned on a couple of
occasions
um and um you know stayed with him for
in subsequent years of his life as well
um you know when when maradona left
napoli he left i think it's fair to say
under a bit of a cloud
after the first ban that he was handed
by fifa
but those memories don't really smear
the kind of image of diego maradona and
the reverence that he's held in
by neapolitans today you can walk the
streets of napoli and find
you know shrines to the player he's
genuinely really regarded as a saint in
that city
and you know it's the singular talent
that i mentioned
which is why people love him as they do
and i believe the italian prime minister
has also
already reacted as well talk to us about
what made
maradona so magical uh well it's partly
the kind of effortless control of a
football it's his
liquid movement around the pitch um you
know those those
moments that are just um you know part
of footballing folklore like i said that
goal against england
at the world cup in 1986 and of course
the one that preceded it the hand of god
yeah um you know those things are just
the fabric
the history of football and like i said
everybody every football supporter who
you know whether they saw him or not i
think
can very easily conjure in front of
themselves the pictures of diego
maradona running around a football pitch
just because he was such a singularly
talented player
um and one who produced heroics for
argentina you know
um a country so passionate about the
game
and of course for napoli in a city
that's also so passionate
um that's why he really is um a titanic
figure in the history of football
but is he i mean he dominated
international football it's kind of a
really unfair question to
uh to put you to put to you but is he
the greatest
footballer of all time well yeah he's
regarded as very many people as very
uh by very many people also by very many
um you know very knowledgeable people
people who don't need to qualify their
opinions
as one of the greatest players if not
the greatest player of all time
essentially that i think is a bit of an
open question he was actually voted
fifa's player of the century of the the
last century yeah alongside brazilian
legend pele so
i think it depends who you ask but like
i say what really matters is
um the memories that everybody has of
diego maradona the moments of magic that
he produced um
and you know wherever you fall on the
question of whether he was or wasn't the
greatest of all time you have to admit
that
he's in with contention and
unforgettable absolutely
dw's tom conoy thank you so much greatly
appreciate it